y hubo sorpresa en el premio nobel de
fisiología o medicina 2021 las apuestas
señalaban a las vacunas de rn que han
permitido combatir el cob y 19 pero
finalmente la academia sueca optó por
los biólogos moleculares estadounidenses
david julius harden pata putian un
reconocimiento al hallazgo de los
receptores que permiten a los humanos
sentir la temperatura y el tacto
es increíblemente emocionante se trata
de uno de nuestros sentidos y todos
sabemos lo importante que es sentir el
entorno para nuestra supervivencia
los científicos encontraron receptores
en la piel que responden al calor y la
presión para lograrlo julius de la
universidad de california usó capsaicina
el componente activo de los chiles para
identificar sensores nerviosos que
permiten que la piel responda al calor
pata putian biólogo y neurocientífico
armenio criado en líbano y nacionalizado
estadounidense encontró sensores
nerviosos sensibles que responden al
tacto sus descubrimientos abren todo un
campo de la farmacología especialmente
para tratar el dolor así lo explica el
propio
y todos sabemos que hay una falta real
de medicamentos y enfoques para tratar
el dolor crónico eso es en parte el
porqué tenemos una epidemia de opioides
ramsus de este campo de investigación ya
habían obtenido otros prestigiosos
reconocimientos julius cuenta con el
premio príncipe de asturias y el break
show de los nobel son los premios al
conocimiento más populares del mundo en
la presente edición se cumplen 120 años
desde el primer galardón actualmente el
premio consta de una medalla y una
recompensa de 1 1 millón de dólares el
pasado año el premio nobel fue al
descubrimiento del virus de la hepatitis
c